我作为我爸爸唯一的亲生的女儿，
我至少可以继承我爸爸的那一半的财产，
对不对？
但如果说我现在就跟我爸撕破脸要这20万的话，
可能我爸和我之间会产生嫌弃，
那么现在这价值七八百万的房产，
将来他未必就给我了，
我感觉不划算。
那你们三个问题，
两个是关于遗产和资产相关的，
还有一个是个人情感，
希望姐你们帮忙支个招。
我自己的情况是28岁，
我在一线城市本科工作五年，
目前的工作是稳定的，
有收入，
但是我自己不太满意这份工作。
我从小是和我爸妈、
外公外婆长大的，
12岁的时候呢，
我亲妈走了，
六年级的时候被我爸送到了寄宿学校，
因为不适应那边的环境，
所以我又转回来和外公外婆一起生活，
每周末的时候，
我爸会过来看我一下。
13岁了以后，
我爸找了个后妈，
14岁我亲外婆走了，
我外公照顾我到高二，
同年我爸和我后妈领了结婚证。
你爸和你后妈领结婚证是在外婆走之前还是走之后？
走之后高三一直到现在和老爸和后妈一起生活，
在他们买的房子里，
我后妈有一个儿子。
他与我爸和他亲妈在他高二高三，
也就是我高三的时候和他们住过一年，
他高三了以后就出国了，
你爸和你的后妈领结婚证的时候，
你当时是多少岁？
应该是15岁，
你后妈的亲儿子多少岁？
比我小一岁14，
因为你的后妈亲儿子也是你后妈有抚养权的是不是？
是的，
也是跟你爸生活在一起的是不是？
你也跟这个后妈也生活过一段时间是不是？
对，
但是我是在18岁的时候才跟他开始一起生活的，
那你15岁这个时候你是跟谁生活呢？
外婆外婆走了就跟外公同个地方，
就平时住诗什么的都是在外公外婆家里是吧？
是的，
好，
这个很重要。
你接着说，
我妈妈离开以后，
我外公外婆和我的爸爸做了财产公证，
据我现目前的情报了解，
我妈妈是有部分遗产留给我的，
但因为我当时未成年，
所以我爸暂时保管这部分费用。
之后不是后妈来了，
我爸和后妈一起全款买了一套房子。
现在住的房子根据老年人就是我爷爷奶奶的说法，
我爸是动用了我妈留给我的那部分钱去买了这套房子。
对，
没有办法确定这个房子到底是写了谁的名字，
那我能确定我和后妈的儿子的名字都不在上面，
所以你知道你现在住的这个房子写的谁的名字是吧？
对，
我不知道，
你去交一趟物业费，
去交一套什么费，
去查一下物业，
查一下就知道了，
OK,
好的，
这个之后我去确认一下。
为什么会涉及到这个问题，
是因为我上班以后，
我逐渐发现和后妈生活起居习惯对不上，
我想搬出去住，
我把这个想法告诉了我的奶奶和姑姑，
他们俩是建议我把这笔钱拿到了，
你再搬出去，
很有可能担心后妈会做事儿，
因为他现在儿子不在国内，
他自己也生病，
万一后面有什么事儿了，
就是扯不清了。
关于这一块儿，
我想问问看，
在法律上我是否能争取到，
争取的可能性高不高，
或者有没有其他办法让我爸把我的名字和份额加上，
这是第一个问题，
那你大概了解一下，
你妈妈生前是干什么工作的，
你的爸爸妈妈在你十几岁的时候，
他们的资产是一个什么级别，
大概有多少钱，
你能分到的份额大概占比多少？
20，
现在你住的这套房子它值多少钱呢？
700~800，
当时买的时候花了多少钱呢？
500，
那我可能不建议你去跟你爸，
因为。
当20万去撕撕破脸，
为什么呢？
因为现在你爸和你的后妈他们的财产价值的话，
是以百万为单位的，
而你去争这个利益的话，
是以20万为单位的，
这是不划算的，
我还不如说让爸爸觉得我不太计较这个事儿，
这样的话，
我作为爸爸的唯一的亲生的女儿，
因为你爸爸和后妈没有再生嘛，
对，
我作为我爸爸唯一的亲生的女儿，
我至少可以继承我爸爸的那一半的财产，
对不对？
但如果说我现在就跟我爸撕破脸，
要这20万的话，
可能我爸和我之间会产生嫌隙，
那么现在这价值七八百万的房产，
将来他未必就给我了，
我感觉不划算，
OK,
好的，
我主要担心是因为我爸和我妈身体都不好，
我也不想撕破脸皮，
但是很多我的亲戚朋友希望我把妈妈的遗产给拽回来，
不要让被妈拿走，
后妈那个弟弟是她带来的弟弟，
又不是你爸他带来的弟弟和前夫啊，
对呀，
所以你是你爸爸的亲生的孩子，
这个时候没必要撕破脸，
因为现在你后妈和你爸爸的总的资产是以几百万为单位来计算了，
咱们就算公平一点说，
假设这个房子值800万，
其中400万归你爸，
400万归你后妈的话，
那你爸的那一部分他肯定是想给你嘛，
因为你是亲生的嘛，
他后面带过来你的儿子又不是亲生的，
我凭啥给他呢？
那这样的话，
咱一算账的话，
咱没必要。
后后眼好的行，
那我想再确认一下，
如果说的不好听，
如果我爸先走了，
那这个房子的顺位继承是先给后妈的，
对吧？
不是这样子的啊，
假设这个房子认定为是他们俩的夫妻共同财产，
如果这个房子市场价值800万，
那么其中有400万是你后妈的，
另外的400万是你爸爸的，
还是他走在前面，
就会发生一次法定继承，
你的后妈，
你的那个没有血缘关系的弟弟，
包括你的爷爷奶奶，
如果健在的话，
都有继承的资格，
都是平均来分这400万的，
所以呢，
这个对于你来说是非常的不划算的啊。
当然理性的做法应该是你爸爸在生前要白纸黑字的立下遗嘱，
他去世之后，
他能够分到的这个400万的份额应该由你个人单独继承，
与他人无关，
甚至与你将来的配偶也没有关系，
要白纸黑字写下来，
这样对你来说更公平一点，
OKOK,
好的，
谢谢，
谢谢。
第二个问题是外公相关的遗产，
我外公他现在有两套房子，
一套是以前住着我和我亲生爸爸妈妈和他们夫妻俩外公外婆的，
然后另一套呢，
是为了我买了一个小区的学区房，
因为拆迁嘛，
学区房变成。
新的妈妈和外婆离世了以后呢，
我外公就一直住着那个大房子，
小房子就一直没动，
他今年的想法是把那个大房子卖了，
然后呢，
他去住学区房去，
我现在困扰的是这个大房子卖出去以后的我的房款该怎么处理，
大概的金额是在500多万吧，
你我现在只能独生女吗？
独生女也就是你的妈妈血脉就你一个人，
也就是说外公的血脉就剩你一个人了，
是不是对是这种情况的话，
如果你外公信得过你的话，
其实是在外公生前过户分好一点。
他现在的想法是他变了两次，
一次是希望给我买一套150万到200万的房子给我住，
就当我的婚前，
之前什么留个100万给他看病，
其他的就正常的，
就该给我，
给我第二个想法呢，
我们买一个稍微高价，
就是550买出，
550买入，
因为考虑到我现在还是未婚的状态，
想考虑到未来的事情，
第三个他昨天新的想法就是每个月给我打6000块钱，
让我搬出去租，
那我是唯一的血脉嘛，
是不是？
那你跟我是做的什么样子，
挺好的，
我们每周都有联系，
其实如果外公去世了之后，
我不知道你的爸爸和外公在你的妈妈去世了之后，
还有没有经常生活在一起，
没有，
你妈妈去世了之后，
你的爸爸就没有跟外。
都经常生活在一起了是吧？
对，
那就不涉及到你爸爸有继承的资格的问题了，
那其实就你了，
可能跑手续会比较麻烦，
那要不现在也死亡证明，
要开各种各样的继承顺位的证明啊，
要开各种各样的证明啊，
有关系的证明啊，
就比较麻烦一点，
现在因为又出现了个情况，
所以我很担心他这一部分财产，
他的亲兄弟姐妹来惦记他了，
打电话给我，
说让她来从老家来上海照顾外公，
如果是这样的话，
那真的要提早做安排，
就在外公在世的时候，
直接去把房产办过户，
过户到你的名下，
然后给外公设一个永久居住的权利，
这样外公也踏实一点。
明白你的意思是大房子不要卖，
这两个房子都可以过户给我，
对，
是的，
这样的金额，
手续费之类的是最小的是吗？
具体的手续费这方面我建议你是问当地的中介，
是通过买卖的方式更划算，
还是通过赠与的方式更划算，
对好的好的，
其他的话我羡慕，
钱没有了，
我还挺害怕的，
我管不住，
我怕外公被骗什么之类的，
外公是有退休金的，
是不是有的，
那我觉得你还是对外公还要多关照嘛，
要关照外公的心理，
要关照外公的健康。
其实人老了之。
很容易被骗的，
很容易被骗，
有可能这兄弟姐妹叔伯子侄都来了，
很容易被骗啊。
最后还有一个小问题，
关于我未来那一半的，
我去年谈了个朋友，
就聊了快半年左右了吧，
我目前现在这个状况，
要不要和男方说，
因为后期肯定会涉及到买房子啊之类的，
先不说，
你先把你的事儿都落尽了，
都是你个人的婚前的财产了。
其实我觉得不管跟谁谈恋爱，
没有必要让他知道我上来就有大几百万的房产，
没有必要，
好的行，
那谢谢姐姐，
谢谢啊，
拜拜，
这简直是集万千宠爱于一生，
外公外婆也是个独生女，
她又是个独的外孙女儿，
爸爸这头也就他一个，
又没有再生别的弟弟妹妹，
外公外婆留下来的财产，
两套房加起来得小1000万了吧，
爸爸，
这一头房产的话，
小400万了吧，
如果我拿了这个剧本的话，
我都不知道我能有多开心，
如果龙飞姐拿到的是这样的剧本的话，
可能就没有龙飞姐了，
因为我就不会经历那么多苦难，
不会被人这么瞧不起，
不会有那么奋发图强，
不会有这些人情冷暖的感悟，
不会有这些阴谋背叛的经历了啊，
就不会有龙飞姐了。
记得点赞关注哦。